[Music]
oh
well i'll point i'll tell you what i
don't have joe schmo but i'll tell you
what i can do for you the specials
yes
we're on season 2 this is season two
we're on season two the only there's
that's it
seven more episodes and the cash reunion
they did a year ago during covet also
that's so sad we have that
don't be sad we're not done yet be
excited we're still going through it
exactly the same
you think we're growing up i know
i louis has really turned out to be my
favorite
you see booger you know him and frozen
have a lot in common they both still
have an xbox 360.
what you do have a 360 do you unite am i
lying yes okay it's been two years two
years oh it's even better we fast
forwarded two years yes
and i suppose quite a lot has changed
i love you
yes
hilly's engaged to be married
what
we really jumped ahead a little too fast
i think we're sure yeah we did last one
was season at 1-6 right
yeah yeah so no we are on the right yeah
this is the right next episode
[Applause]
[Music]
whoa
what
is that hodar oh mike is this guy also
tarted
because he doesn't look tarted right he
just looks like eric but goes in oh my
god dean someone new have you ever been
single lucy
never
uh
ho alert
megan is in our last year at college
this is preparation for work is that
right right
yes we're all in the right place that's
good
hello and i got a job
hey there
hey look who's making money teddy bear
making money moves
yes
[ __ ] that's my boy though i know you i
sam's my boy but he got this team sam
sack what did you do with the box
instead of putting the prices on them
he got fired
yeah and now he's back at college but
he's got big plans for his future
firefighter
businessman
oh the president well good luck one of
those three things for sure you have the
mental capacity for now yeah
is it too late
to rewrite our constitution to allow
foreigners that weren't born in this
country to run
we already did obama was president i'll
take sam over this [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh who knows
[ __ ] awesome
he wants to be your next president where
did they go where did they go
that was for him and megan
well that got a bit complicated
it means sandwich at once
he's wow it
my man
didn't go very well
see james sam versus team lewis
[Music]
how was he acting like an idiot
oh
i love louis
i thought he was gonna be the weirdest
one on the show but he ended up being my
favorite one did you notice he stopped
with the cell phone too
yeah
but now things are back to normal
well
they're still pretty [ __ ]
come
here oh no he does he has an iphone now
oh no this is gonna be way worse now oh
god he's never gonna put that [ __ ]
thing down oh [ __ ] me
no
[Music]
and we're back to having fun in bra oh
she got braces huh isn't that getting
like getting rims on a 1984 dressel
hey hey look look
sam dressed up as a sloth from the
goonies
no that's just his face
it's a superman
oh god i didn't notice that you're right
you notice the superman shirt
that's amazing
hey you guys
oh no she's going as a black person
somewhere
thing she says allowed
what is hell
[Music]
[Laughter]
war never changes
now we're doing [ __ ] fallout
[Laughter]
since last we left you sam tried to blow
up megaton
[Laughter]
but he's [ __ ] and he just blew
himself up
oh [ __ ] could you imagine if they did an
ending like new vegas but with the
retards oh man yeah remember when they
did the everyone did the voice over in
their own voice like whatever guy they
were talking about they let that actor
do that part of the story
that would be the [ __ ] way to do it
right
uh
let's see
after the ncr took the hoover dam
chief lewis decided that war was no
longer for him and he retired back to
the new california republic okay
can i try one
true
okay
what do you just play the fallout
no i'm doing this one i'm doing a
different i'm doing a different movie
oh writing down with the machine it was
suddenly clear the terminator would
never stop
it would never leave him and it would
never hurt him
never shout at him or get drunk at him
so i say
he was too busy spending time with him
sorry
back to the show
okay hillary would end up moving on into
the desert
her life forever changed by the courier
oh
[ __ ]
here here you go check out check out
here
[Laughter]
with with mr house's securitrons now
online
new vegas became a safe haven for
everyone to come and enjoy themselves
i muted so i wouldn't laugh over it
nobody ever knew what became of joshua
graham
but the tribes in utah were grateful
for all he had done to unite them
and then there's just one non-retard the
ncr rangers ended up taking over hoover
dam and pushing all the way east and
eliminating caesar's legion and then it
just goes back to another [ __ ] lewis
got a new iphone
oh
my
christ retards and video games man
that's a hit
why aren't we doing more of that
why are we not doing more retards in
video games
god damn that was really funny lean and
mean a mission
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
game over man game over
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] dude
if it could if it can bleed we can kill
it
where do we get the sequel to the
specials the second season when they're
on a spaceship stuck with aliens but
paul reiser's in it oh no and he's there
to represent the interests of the
corporations i'm ready for specials
three rise of the machines there you go
[ __ ] robots
and that's great because nick stahl is
and then he's [ __ ] already [ __ ]
i ain't got no time to breathe
come on guys
this is our what by the way i just want
to point something out because i want to
make people sad just real quick just
make people sad
back up just a little bit these are the
people that are beating you in call of
duty just so you know
wait is he rocky training yeah he's
rocky training he's chasing the chicken
and we want to share it with you
[Music]
louis i'm gonna have you eating thunder
and crap and lightning
please stop crapping in the bed
he's a killer
he'll go across a mark
that's really mean
wow we didn't even make it through the
intro oh my god we're only two minutes
in merch
holy [ __ ]
just [ __ ] talking [ __ ]
whoops
oh
it took us 15 minutes to get through
those two minutes